foreign
so um I wanted to kind of answer your
last question about like isn't that a
raw deal for the guy like you know if
she's gotten with you know 10 guys and
then she decides that you know she
doesn't want to be that way anymore she
wants to wait till marriage
yeah yeah go ahead
so I think it depends on how you look at
it right like if she's come to a like
point in a realization that you know
sleeping with all these guys isn't
fulfilling her and she's
you know done you know self-evaluation
and healing right and like understanding
her value I really think that the issue
today is a lack of self-value right or a
lack of valuing love
so like if she's come to that point
she's grown right so let's say she
hasn't slept with someone for two years
now she's been working on herself and
then she meets another guy like I think
that's a different picture right where
she really wants to make it work with
this guy but she's learned that like you
know just letting him have it you know
on the third date or whatnot doesn't
lead to that serious relationship who
determines what's valuable
well I would say like value comes like
it's mixed with morality right like so
like
you know being quote unquote good right
like do you like cheat and steal right
like how do you carry yourself like are
you one way in front of other people are
you like different behind closed doors
like when I talk about value like
valuing myself if I'm talking personally
like I knew I had been through a lot of
BS in my life and guys and
um so even before meeting my husband I
said like I'm not going to be with
anybody for two years like that's it I'm
not doing like one night stands I'm not
doing anything like I don't I can't even
be in a relationship with anybody like
my picker is off because the last guy I
was with was abusive and I realized that
I picked I was picking people that I was
trying to save right like I can't save
and like fix them if I'm effed up and
I'm picking people that are gonna hit me
right or be this way so I just said like
no I'm not going to be with anyone and I
met my now husband and we you know we
had sex before marriage and
like I've loved him since day one you
know I knew he was gonna be my husband
but he swore he would never get married
again you know but like but you didn't
but you didn't make him do the internal
healing and also like lead him into more
healing as well and like we've healed so
so you had sex with him before you were
married
oh yeah yeah but yeah yeah but that's
what I'm saying like you didn't require
marriage to have sex with him
and so I just think if I was in a
delusion you know and like you were
entering wages war against the soul and
like what do you mean you're in a
delusion and it's not
a delusion sorry this just doesn't make
any sense to me uh because it's like
like when you're brought up in the
delusional world like you think like you
need to have sex before you get married
to find out if you even want to be with
this person
but but I'm saying so you got the
outcome of marriage and you had sex
before you were married with your
husband I just want to make sure I'm
understanding it
yeah yeah but like for a year and a half
before we got married finally like I
kept hearing in my mind like you should
be married you know and I like I knew I
should but I didn't feel like I could
bring it up with him which is which is
I'm not judging you I'm just saying that
like to me that makes sense because you
weren't a virgin so of course you're
gonna have sex like why would you make
the next guy wait when you let the last
guy have it for free but from a man's
point of view like why on Earth would he
wait for a marriage for a woman that's
not a virgin why would he take why would
he take every possible risk legally or
you can take the kids you can take the
house you can take the money when
again he doesn't even get a virgin at
the end of it
right
like if she had she has a higher
understanding of healing and like her
value at that point like so she's but
she's not but see you say her value
she's not valuable to men if she's had a
whole face it's like you can't just
magically make it go away in your values
more it's less and so it's like you're
acquiring a higher price for a worse
product
depend but see it depends to me it
depends on your relationship with God
like that's really what's most valuable
not not to me at all to women not to Men
You're hard-pressed hard-pressed to find
a virgin today like were they at like
they're pretty non-existent right but
there's there's a plethora of girls
that'll sleep with you for before Merit
but this is just like I'm just
explaining it to you I I understand
where you're coming from and I used to
think like that but from the guy's point
of view why on Earth would he wait when
he could just
like why does he have to wait when the
last guy got it for free and then he
he's not even getting a virgin The
Waiting should be like two years like
these these other people were saying
like I mean if you know you know
so so you think that they should wait
for married and just marriage and just
get married quick
it depends on their understanding and
like what marriage is to them so like if
marriage is a covenant before God then
yes if marriage is just a piece of paper
where now you guys share assets then no
it doesn't matter right but if it's a
covenant before like it you just when
men hear that you've had a hoe phase and
then you want to get married and now
conveniently you're good with God it's
like where was that good with God when
you were [ __ ] Tyrone and Chad it
wasn't there yeah but that's right
that's the that's the whole point that's
the whole point is like it's just it's
just mad hold on hold stop wait wait so
this is this is the whole point is that
it's just mad convenient it's like now
when you want marriage now you're right
with God it could it could be viewed
that way and I'm sure some people do do
that too but see the thing is like we're
people think oh we're all children of
God that's not true you're not a child
of God unless you're born again unless
you accept Jesus as your savior you're
not so like let's say you know you were
running a month for the first 25 years
of your life
well when you come to know that yeah
you're evil and you need to repent then
that in that repentance comes change
right so that change that's why some
girls say I'm not going to do it till
marriage because like their relationship
with God means more than having sex or
like does that make sense no it I
understand where you're coming from I
just think it leaves women single
I think that's why when I walk into a
church I see I see so many single women
doesn't matter catholic christian
Protestant it's just single women
everywhere
and it's because I think they're trying
to sell a used Honda Civic for BMW
prices
well but like another thing I wanted to
bring up with you too is like besides
the sex point it's like how do they
treat their man right like a lot of
women that I know like friends or
whatnot like they can become resentful
and then they withhold love and it's
like dude like you guys both have wounds
right so like when you see your man's
wounds the solution is not to then hold
back right the solution is to love him
more and like my husband's you know much
older than me right so he had a lot more
wounds than I did even though I had a
lot but because I was able to
continuously like love him like those
walls broke down right so like I feel
like that's another problem in society
where people women I want to say younger
women think that the men need to grovel
or they need to come back or they need
to beg for it and it's like okay so you
guys ultimately both want love so you're
50 of this equation right but you're
manipulating you're manipulating in a
way that's actually decreasing what you
want right so like you can't say I want
love and then pull back and play these
games games of like well I'm not going
to be this way until he's that way what
if the man says I want sex
before marriage should she cooperate
what do you mean so if she's religious
and the guy says I want to get married
to you but I want sex first should she
cooperate
well the thing is like first and
foremost she's married to Christ if
she's truly born again so like that
that's a no-go like that's just that
just doesn't happen so so would you say
she's wishy-washy I mean yeah if she
feels she needs to give her body in
order to keep this guy but that's on her
like she has to she has to deal with
that do you think it's better to die
alone than cooperate
meaning like cooperate with having yeah
like with having sex before marriage
um I don't think so no I would never
want to die alone okay
no it's just interesting because that
just seems to be the outcome a lot of
churches are pushing
yeah I heard you say something
why would like younger men want to go to
church or like that kind of would turn
them off from that because it's like
okay these women have already been
rambling through or whatnot and then now
they're saying okay we gotta wait you
know it actually would make guys it
would church right but like
the turn on for for church should be not
wanting to go to hell should be like
understanding that we either
you know accept Christ or we go to hell
like if you don't believe that or if
that's not like what's
the biggest issue then it really doesn't
matter that's what you do and I
understand where you're coming from but
like I'm just telling you to men it
doesn't seem genuine when all these
girls happen to come back when they need
a husband
it probably isn't
okay thank you for calling in appreciate
it as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible